[Musik]
mack und battle hole ich in zehn minuten
nach unten dort mit ph und bauaufgaben
bekannte mich aber mach s p gebraucht
und zum baumarkt weil ich noch nicht
brauchen und bleibt auch bei
jugendlichen vor aber überhaupt
irgendwas heute gestartet als leiter der
block sehen wollt ich wollte mich
übrigens aber bei euch bedanken dass ich
dann euch sein leben leben davon anhalt
deine fresse ich wirklich nur einfriert
findet ihr es eigentlich gut wenn ich
die kamera teilen musste irgendwo stehen
habe ich beispielsweise vor und dann
mach ich mal nebenbei darf was ich die
ganze zeit im block machen würde oder
findet ihr besser so ein bisschen so
wendig und freihändig somit dem stativ
mache das teil wieder verzweifelt sind
gerade 22 grad draußen soll ich jetzt
eine kurze hose anhat oder eine lange
hose weil begegnen soll
auch das macht und öl mit 4 3
das ist nicht wahr ich scheiße weil die
beiden jungs haben einfach kurze hosen
kommen und gehen
dein haus dann kommen kleine maus eine
computermaus sätze nicht gedacht ich
gehe an und mich auf das leid zu lindern
bestimmt so 100 1000 ps oder 150
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
9 euro 60 bühnengraben alter brauchen
futter rahmen so heiße wetter und die
haben wie gesagt kurz rosen an und ich
bin voll am verrecken
ich hab mal ein glas geklaut jede stufe
muss bieten sonst hat man etwa zwei cent
leben schön dass du da bleibt doch
einfach danke für die erklärung
siehst du deine eltern mit blut
glaspokal 49 cent wir müssen das meeting
vertagen ist im urlaub da zustimmen muss
du dich nicht eigentlich hinstellen mal
oder dicht anlage eine sache gerne
vanilla ice vor diese ganzen bösen uhr
karten an tagen die leute findet ihr
nicht auch wenn ich am ende kommentiert
über klassiker ist einfach der beste
ende ist leute wenn ihr das cool findet
was wir heute machen damit her
interessant findet das einfach mal keine
ahnung 70 da und dann verliebte also
lesen etwa auf jeden fall verwenden
bieten glaubt
an
lukas für 90 minuten hinter gitter
es ist einfach alles voller pakete ich
würde gar nicht und marktleute durchweg
trocken schnitt raus ich bin gerade live
video dabei ich wollte mal sagen
abonniert main kanal effektivität und
effizient mit auf jeden fall ganz groß
geschrieben wird
wir holen uns eine karte um selbst zu
schieben der unseren strand trägt focus
eigentlich zwei mann zelt 90 euro
schauen wir wie es aussieht kommt
klingt gerade youtube wir sind erst von
ikea vom baum
die sache ist habe ich gott ist groß von
denen wir zu hause abgesetzt damit ich
mich ja noch eine kurze hose gehen kann
und ob die kamera holen weil ich jetzt
wieder zurücklaufen damit wir noch
videos aufnehmen kann
eigentlich schon wieder zwei stunden
später und zeitmanagement ich ganz groß
geschrieben bei uns für leiter luca
einem kader und ein video auf ihre mid
die kammer geklaut
marken jahren endlich haben wir ein
schönes bild hier
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so leute die ja schon mit den noch bei
mir gab auch ein bisschen feiern um so
die geschafften klausuren zu zelebrieren
also freude wenn euch der glocke teilen
hat lacht gern vom bliebe uns morgen
nicht so dumm zu wird sich meine tür
wir sehen uns morgen wir einen blog
[Musik]